[Music]
my name is one and hurts me I'm a
grandmaster I was well champion under
sixteen and that's what the introduction
finishes so that's it you know we'll
stop here
what just is about you know when you ask
young kids they start with big words
that I never understand like strategy
and all those big huge beautiful worlds
that may be correct
not at the very not at the very
beginning you know but the our expert in
the crowd and our class a big players
how do you win chess games yeah tactics
what is tactics
and what you want to get from attacking
upon formation what do you want to get
from attacking upon formation okay so
you want to win material right right I
mean everything everything you know we
go left to right almost all the time
it's get to the one bottom line which is
really material it doesn't matter you
know it's almost hundred percent at
lower levels really really almost
hundred percent at lower levels that
games are being decided just by material
a Claire is blundering a queen a rook is
opponent blunders you know being able to
capitalize on your opponent blunders is
as important as not blundering yourself
you know when you ask when I ask
beginners and let's say unweighted in my
world is pretty much beginners like what
chess is about well it's pretty much a
wall right it's a battle and it's a very
even battle right I mean we have the
white army the black army they are
evenly divided so it's very fair the
territory so far is about the same and
if we have to think very quickly about
what is a battle well we will very very
quickly say that material is crucial
material is the most crucial part if you
have hundred thousand soldiers in your
opponent has ten thousand strategy
becomes much less important right you're
just gonna win most likely and then the
other part is space but also really the
two most important parts why this is why
we fight for the center and all those
things you know add a class here already
with one very nice gentleman that was
telling me that he played chess it was
really interesting that he play chess
for a long long time and he is 1500
about 1500 and he really wants to
improve really he was playing chess for
tens of years
and it was interesting here yelled the
book an excellent book written by one of
the best authors Captain Muller is a
German author a German Grandmaster I
even got to play him once long long ago
this world Cheska fair puzzle books and
many other absolutely excellent book the
only problem that I had was that this
book was so far above what he was
actually needing what was his level so
after we spoke for a little bit I put
one position on the boat for him just
one position that I want I want to start
with this position let me just put a
simple position on the board so I put
this position to this gentleman and I
asked him what should white play this is
someone that has been playing chess for
tens of years like they've read many
told me that he had three four hundred
books which was remarkable in his in its
chest collection what should Bishop
takes Bishop okay and what what will
happen after black captures back Queen
check okay right so you are a fake
unweighted the OFA can write it right
because that's that's not inaugurated to
spot in ten seconds but that's that's
correct now my question is why why after
take we know automatically that black is
going to play this move why why why our
brain immediately tells us that black
will play this move right right right
if you don't want to be down material
because five minutes ago we basically
said I hope you agree but if not then
then it's correct to agree the chess is
a game that's being won by material so
if we win something then most likely the
opponent has to do something bad
this gentleman was saying that you want
to play castle because it makes it make
sense right he wants to have
the king to a safe spot but of course
this continuation is winning the game
immediately capture black and play
basically whatever you want but unless
the capture or have any something else
that is forced we will speak about this
forced word it's down three points and
down three points is losing by the way
this if we are speaking you know today
everything is in computer worlds and
numbers what evaluation is basically
considered winning already these days
less than three if we say that one
player is up X amount of material is
basically considered winning what would
that be many it is very close like I
think most most engines one point five
it's basically they the borderlines form
big big advantage to about winning now
now is the question we will touch all
those points well what is what is
exactly 1.5 I mean I don't know you take
this pawn and cut it in half and it goes
find tiny bit tiny bit different but
right so we understand the three point
is something that unless there is a
reason for that or in other word
compensation that's it okay so take
check and wins the bishop okay excellent
now let's look at another position
okay this is the position and it is why
to play what should I be playing here
you try to play
day five okay what should black play
right and if you doesn't move the night
is going to lose material right right
that's correct when you put when you put
this position too many players
especially at the early stages they will
play either they will move immediately
to attack the night they will play
quindi three you know the little bit
advanced ones of the ones that are
getting the answer wrong because there
are different levels of getting their so
wrong they will play Queen a4 now what
is Queenie for Queen a4 is basically yes
it's a pain that excellent and what is
why it's idea exactly what the gentleman
said yeah we want to play d5 we want to
win the night on this pin and maybe also
win that night the only problem is that
black has many moves that will stop that
right I mean well know how many but at
least two that are incredibly easy to
spot which two moves for black will
immediately stop this threat castle
legacy castle I will play d5 and well I
might have I might have a double attack
here thank you
if b5 I will just take it but Queen d7
I'll play the same apply d5
first of all you know when looking at
every position any any any position its
we have to ask yourself this very simple
question what the opponent want to do
what we want to do so now it's clear
right since I mentioned d5 on any more
white wanna play define 45 okay makes it
not that easy for white to play this
fight that's that that's how it goes
so pawn to d5 no d5 no attacking no easy
another possibility to prevent d5 Knight
f6 for example okay no d5 so when
someone is suggesting Queen a fall to me
I know did they have the right idea but
they just don't have the right way to
actually carry it they wanna play d5
they understand it they might attack the
knight and they might attack the king
but d5 is our most forcing move and the
night either will move or not move the
knight moves we will play check and take
this night the night won't move we're
gonna win two points of material and
we're gonna be winning here let's for a
second let's see if there is an engine
here one second
do we have an engine I'm not certain
okay let me see I don't think we have an
engineer what this know that I see one
quickly but this is maybe at home one
second no because it will be okay well
let's let you see perfect so any other
move nothing absolutely nothing
you know essential thing to show about
nothing this is where we are here
nothing d5 plus minus is winning in our
chess world notation 2.7 so white is
basically almost a full piece up for
free but only move only move so now let
me have you think a little bit and ask
you this question
what is they I will have several
questions first of all let's start what
the advantage of playing a forcing move
or the advantage of thinking about
forcing moves you're in control okay
basically you have easier possibility to
see into the future right because your
opponent reaction is pretty much forced
like the first example that we started
with Bishop takes Bishop for example in
this position without thinking much
White has about I would say 30 moves in
this position that's we can do it
quickly 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17
let's move the bishop 18 19 20 21 22 the
knight 24 I don't remember if I touch
the book probably yes the Queen 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 34 okay it doesn't matter
if it's 35 or 37 so why does 34 legal
moves in this position more or less if I
haven't missed one or two black will
have about the same so for the next
position you have more than thousand
possibilities to have a position you
have more than thousand possibilities
but if you play this move I can play any
of these beautiful thirty moves we know
that he has to do something actually
here it doesn't matter what he will do
is gonna be he's gonna lose the game
anyway so playing a forcing move or
thinking about four singles makes it
much much much easier for us to be able
to see I had I was just speaking tiny
bit before the lecture with someone and
I was telling him the advantage of
forcing move is that well let's take a
position that we worked it there are
five possibilities for us and for the
opponent in general five possibilities
and we want to go five moves deep so
basically each position there are five
possibilities five possibilities five
possibilities we will have to see five
in the power of five which is about 3125
different position that's what we will
have to see
quickly now let's say that we managed to
make magic and narrow those five
possibilities only to two possibilities
and now we want to go ten moves deep
let's doing the power of ten so that's
only 1,024 so look at the amazing part
when we are able to narrow the amount of
possible moves we can go deeper with
much much much less energy much much
less calculation this is the big huge
power of forcing move if you think about
deep blue that was able to see brilliant
positions per second displayed cast
power he was about cast power of level
the matches were very even but today you
know you use Red Cow Houdini one of
those engines and you let them play
against the best plan in the world on a
simple simple PC that they will see
added a few million positions per second
the computer is much stronger than a
human because not because the
calculation power is better just the
software is better so what will be our
forcing moves well what will be our
first but any kind so basically if you
want to attack a high-value piece
basically most of the time you will
force the opponent to react right so you
are going to play a move such as d5 you
are forcing him to react okay so
attacking what else check check easily
is not even logically a forcing move
it's by the rules of the game I the
opponent either has to block movie
skiing or capture that piece let it the
game cannot continue what else those are
two parts there are two others but
they're all in the same family
capture right we've also touched this
one right I capture basically capture is
when I put it in the order that I see
most feet I would say check because
that's that just by definition it's the
most forcing move right doesn't matter
the opponent has to do one of the three
things capture because first of all they
happen most often you know you have
several captures in the game quite many
so captures attacking high-value piece
and one other idea this is actually the
top if I have to break down attacking
high-value piece usually I'll stop
attacking the Queen but we have seen
that attacking a knight is also very
forcing exactly your opponent can do
whatever you want if you are tightening
mate exactly so seriously those are the
moves that really quite incredible you
cannot really ignore them and the times
that you ignore them which actually I
was thinking that that will be part of
my lecture remember I started by depends
on the audience when you ignore captures
maybe I will show after it's just one
game that I thought was magic when I was
young it's one of the game between
Kasparov and Karpov and really it was it
was played I think in the first match in
1985 there very very first one that cup
that basically was stopped and he some
made some magic there I thought all my
life that that was a magic yes it was
cut it was Karpov was white Karpov was
white it was in the 85 85 85 85 match
maybe game nine but way we might get to
it okay so we understand this part the
part of forcing move let me show just
one more one or two more positions that
has to do with this idea because I want
to touch also something else that has to
do tiny bit with people that suggesting
those
and as opposed to d5 let me show one
more position let's say the board
white is to play here how should I play
take the night with the bishop okay
that's a good move but what will you
play after he takes okay
but what if he will stop it right that
was the one tiny part that you miss to
be perfect but that was excellent
excellent so we start with well the
easiest part is when they are captures
on the boat right I mean there are three
captures okay so we take and sometimes
if you see some chests which really
really beginners it's sometimes kind of
funny because they have a capture
letting the opening if you start a Foley
five-night of three so we all know the
main moves okay knight c6 or Knight f6
but let's say that you will see a almost
an animated tournaments of kids not like
our smart kid heritage
and let's say they play ridiculous
second movie flicks
so now of course white should take the
pawn right but sometimes you will see no
instead of taking he wants to put more
pressure played if ball three it can
fire because I want to attack the
opponent take it it's used so we don't
need it here we start with the capture
okay now here it is interesting
I found this position to be fascinating
and I didn't put it by accident because
100 percent of the people that I show
this position suggested this move
hundred percent but here comes the
tricky part I would say about half of
them and actually took quite a lot of
position to quite a lot of that half of
them suggest Bishop take King take
Queenie for check King move somewhere
and take of course white is better in
this position but okay it is not you
know it's not the clearest position in
the world I mean yeah white white should
be winning here I mean it's up quite a
lot of material maybe black has to make
effort somehow to open the bishop but
yeah all in all this is position that
white is going to be winning but after
this move
this is the position that black stops
the clock and resign because he's
getting checkmated Oh is gonna lose this
walk right
so when we started and the gentleman
here mentioned the tactics are for
getting something getting your idea it's
really really really most of them at
least the reasonable level are getting
just material yes at higher level
players we see some super complicated
tactics the entire idea is just to
create some weakness in the opponent
position but this is not where we are
really here okay so this was one very
very important topic that I wanted to
touch the topic that has to do with four
signals that we very easily identify
them they all have to do it material or
the king attacking material captures
checking or threatening shipment you can
divide it into two parts the King and
among the pieces material okay this is
one position one part now let's go a
second touch like the other part because
you know it is our first lecturing I
think that it will be interesting to
give tools how to think about chess in
the general in the general term the
general order looking at the position we
said before that a player can be up 1.5
points of material without cutting pawns
into a half of nights into whatever and
so on how can it be how can a computer
will put the position and will say let's
look for example a disposition in
purpose I want to put this one actually
I want to take one step back and discuss
this one more so if we look at the
position here and we are counting we
will say that white took upon and it
took a walk
so why took six points of material right
those were just ferric changes and he
gave his Bishop so white should be
three material three points of material
up why this is in our in our normal
world if I click on the computer here
which I'm going to do in a minute do you
think that the computer will say that
white is up three points of material
that white is up less than three points
of material more about removal less
Wireless the queen is not placed okay
okay so this point is although maybe
capturing this pawn I'm just thinking
maybe speaking again about forcing ideas
and so on
can i maybe castle by taking the be shop
and now if you're going to defend it
what we will play after defending it
c3 right yeah we'll put more pressure on
against this pin and i think we're going
to have excellent chances of winning
this one I mean there might be some
other possibilities here but so the
gentleman here said that white will be
less than three points down of material
because of the Queen okay any any other
thoughts
so black might move the Queen for
example and if I will take castle then
black will be able to play Bishop a6 the
walk will be attacking the Queen because
don't forget we moved our queen away and
the bishop will win material if white
will castle there I think that white
will castle the other side I think that
is sorry
okay okay so here it is the interesting
first of all let's let's just close one
topic and then we're going to open
another big one
the same way that players play Queen a
foe in the position that d5 was
attacking the knight and winning
immediately you know you know I always I
always compare it to I'd know
diving into Olympiad now somehow it's
interesting because they have two two
ways to get there great one one is by
difficulty and the other one is by the
way that they perform their dive right
it's always like this so I think in a
chess position in a chess tactics we
really have to two factors that have to
work together for us to play their
correct move one we have to see the idea
you know when I speak with students I
don't care about moves moves are
meaningless what is they move what a
move okay you can you can I randomly
choose a move but a plan no you cannot
randomly Cho choose a plan or an idea so
white here has to spot before we even
start has to spot the connection between
this square to the hook and to the path
but is this enough it's not enough to
play correct this is the two parts that
we need one to spot the idea then we
need to find the best way to actually
make it work exactly exactly
you know I have a great idea you know I
want to create a much better search
engine than Google the only problem is I
can barely open the computer turn it on
so you know other than that I have a
genius idea it can be great but I can
barely turn on the computer which is
true so you know it's two it's two parts
in chess I do tiny better and at least I
hope so I see the connection you know
this is by the way why doing puzzles we
will tiny bit speak how
can improve and do that but having the
idea somewhere the connection this is
the base because yeah if your pond
blunder a piece okay move you tonight
and take it this is fairly simple right
it's to most combination take so this is
something hugely important you think you
have a great idea it's not enough how
you going to make it work now we will
skip quickly to our position let's let
me ask you a question if we said that
there are four forcing types of forcing
moves checked captures attacking I value
pieces and threatening treatment
great now let me ask you a question you
see a position in chess you say this
position you see any position any any
any position does it matter if it's
being played by a young kid being played
by an amateur a master Grandmaster
Magnus Carlsen actually there it's
almost not important the position it's
just winning anyway but but let's say
let's say that yeah doesn't matter
interested but let's say that you see a
position what will be the characters of
the position what which factors would
you be looking to say I think white is
better I think black is better I think
he turned what will you be putting in
your formulas which care which factors
development one of them but yes but but
this is much deeper I know you're right
but this is tiny bit a much deeper idea
this I would say maybe this is like
future possibilities yes but I would say
that the five did I wanna mention maybe
I'm wrong but I think that they will be
quite perfect for 95 98 99 percent of
the positions because they are really
what's on the surface tiny bit more
future threat it of course you're right
but it's a deeper concept than the
simple one that I wanna mention
development right where are my pieces
well your pieces but they are much much
before that much King safety is
excellent okay but much before that
great dot two out of five
okay material yeah I mean you know
before I look at the position before I
understand I you know I know how to
count right white is up three points of
material no that's all I know I look at
the position its material game seriously
the more that beginners amateurs
cloudless understand the chess is
material game seriously yes you know
some strong players can win amazing
position with one weakness but what to
do say material game fo for for then
also you know today I don't know if
someone it's in some games from Tata
Steel formerly known as we can see I
don't know Magnus Carlsen the best
player in the world beat who I found
the second best women player in the
world after Judit Polgar one point one
pawn that's all he had one pawn after
move 1213 carried it on the final
position was a queen well his pawn was
about to promote but they played an
endgame that he was one pawn up one one
no check made no Queen up this is how we
win our my wish that we were we team but
this is how chess games are being won
one point that's enough no material okay
that's three out of five so we have
material development King safety I need
two more Center control okay can you put
it tiny bit in a larger concept you're
right tiny bit larger than standard
control because you're right
the center is the most important part of
the board right so I would say instead
of Center control space space to a small
space and if you have more space in the
center in my world it's about the same
right so space and by the way I will put
in my world in most position because
it's the most visual thing before you
start thinking about is the King safe
not ESD you know optically you see the
material and you see where the pieces
are on the board and whether the pawns
so material in space are even quickly
the first one that comes in to the eye
so we need one more
what does position mean
I would say that this is very similar to
what the gentleman here mentioned
basically future threats or future ideas
I agree but I want something even more
visual and easy that's correct it's very
similar idea so we have material we have
space we have pieces development and we
have King safety one more exactly
initiative future threat attacking ideas
all one world but pawn structure both
attacks you
for example this position the pawns are
all okay but you see one player has for
porn Island again it's visual those are
tools that no one is required to be
super strong players you can look with
your eyes and say okay double pawns you
know many people doubled pawns a bit Oh
double pawns can be actually excellent
isolated doubled pawns almost almost
always are ugly poet you see one player
has four pawn islands you know the
beautiful a cf8 beautiful no okay that's
a ugly ugly ugly pawn structure so it's
very easy one player has an isolated D
pawn for free what does it mean for free
for the turf you don't want it doesn't
really have initiative okay so that's a
weakness so pawn structure so now let's
try to think in this position because
this this will be interesting
yes the way that I see it I you know the
two are very easy for me material
because it's it's in instinct you know
an instinct that you look at the
position and you see the material so
material space it's also the most visual
thing I will say then in most position
it is the pieces where the pieces are
development exactly pawn structure and
very rarely you know when the King is
substantially weak than the King safety
but again you know some position can be
like
listen to tell you that hey I ran a
check over two million positions and you
know those are the exact statistics no I
feel that it isn't very very very very
close like it's you know I feel that the
best that I can at least suggestion I
think it's closing right so let's look
at this position because now you know
we'll be funny now after this big
beautiful I'll click on the computer and
you will say white is +4 and then the
st. Louis Club will fire me so that's a
convict not gonna happen Alex what right
so what do we think you I will tell you
what I think and then we will see I
think that white is one move behind he's
skiing so well is one move behind you
know once I was speaking with a student
of mine actually genius kid I mean no
super genius and I was telling him you
know chess is really about material of
space and time and then you know
thinking that I mean the wrong subject
lecturing about physics to someone that
says hundred more IQ than I do but that
really chest so here is the tiny bit
time point this King needs at least one
more move to be safe black also has
those two right you know give them a
chance they can be alive so black has
pair of bishops White Queen is tiny bit
out of play I mean this pawn yeah it's a
pond and in ponds are great that's how
know what we said there are Magnus cars
and today won again but the Queen is
tiny out of play so what should black
play here I suggested the move that I
think is the best one I want to play c5
because when I have those two when my
king is here when the opponent King is
here you know we we should go for a fast
break so see if I would be most logical
and I think that the evaluation will be
much lower than three because you know
how computer work you will say you will
do exactly this material plus three
space X pieces development white pawn
structure Z at the end
he's adding them up give you a number so
let's look which movie thinks is the
best and believe me I don't remember
well maybe in what would you say okay
incredible incredible right unbelievable
so c-51 point so basically right or
wrong okay you know we are kind of today
so funny you know if you're not Houdini
or it's nobody saw Houdini or WIPA
nobody's looking at you but sweetly
laugh and you know was enough probably I
think to beat Kramnik it was deplete
like ten years ago in a mattress the
computers say that after c5 which is the
best move white is up 1.17 1.17 mode at
one point so basically in our world what
it means if we have to speak about it in
words basically mr. computer is saying
that white is up three points of
material but black somewhere has one
point eight in his favor now where is
this summer it might be the center it
might be the bishops it might be that
white need some wrong move it might well
I would say it mainly the center and the
bishop so let's not just look one more
move deeper c5 quintic the pond it you
want it all right take cancel any five
okay so here we take timeout and we look
again the position and we will say oh
now we understand there is some there
are some points here there are some big
shops the Queen is out of play no joke I
mean no joke this is plus one point so
those tools very very basic you know it
doesn't really matter which game you're
seeing whether you are analyzing your
own game whether you are analyzing a
game played by you know world champions
masters anyone in the club there cannot
be any other factors in the position yes
they can be may be tiny bit deeper ones
like we say like future threat or things
like that but really they will all be
measured at some point by those factors
you know some time not hundred percent
perfect so it computer thinking a bit
okay white is winning here this is the
borderline 1.4 1.5 minus plus of the
minus is big advantage plus minus is
winning in in chess world so this is how
we look at those in those positions okay
let's stop for a second and see if we
have any questions or thoughts or ideas
or anything else that you want to ask or
suggest
nothing right so let's summarize very
quickly what we discussed we said that
we want to look at positions in the most
most forcing way we want to start with a
capture a cheque attacking a queen
taking high-value piece threatening
checkmate why it's not necessarily going
to be a good move it's not necessarily
going to be a good move but it's quite
necessarily going to a cliff to lead us
to a conclusion in the fastest way
now if the conclusion is something that
we like great then we have Express
waiter we don't need to look at many
other positions we started our examples
today by this gentleman sitting here
saying oh bishop tell quintic yes that
is a super express way to a conclusion
white is winning this is the advantage
that we have we touched in this position
to two huge parts one the thing the idea
the first part the move order it's
honestly I probably put this position to
tens of people hundred percent of them
suggested this capture not even one did
but then it's amazing half wanted to
capture and take and have probably
played Queen e4 when the opponent should
resign so the idea is one the way to do
it is to and then was very interesting
you know we have some decent experienced
players here yet it wasn't very easy to
really put a number and basically put a
number means to fully understand the
position three-point is game although
this is by no means game over you know
today was a game Nakamura against Giri
and actually this was very similar if
people see today the game from the the
material was actually equal but Gary was
completely winning it was around last
two and okay just played bed in time
trouble and the game finished in a draw
but by no means you know it was a
clear-cut position the same way that
here okay white is a pawn up one and a
half one and a half points
game is not finished
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]